could barbie ever have been
uncontroversial i don't think so
because for the past 50 years femininity
has been a contested space in the past
dolls had all been baby dolls they had
all been about teaching little girls how
to nurture barbie was a wildly
revolutionary toy bar V became things
that real women hadn't become she had
broken barriers these dolls enable girls
to tell stories about dreams she's been
around 55 years but the last few years
have been trying for the Barbie Barbie
was everything we didn't want to be and
we're being told to be some people think
Barbie needs to be liberated you look at
television and film and music and you
see the same body type being idealized
perception of Barbie is that she's vapid
materialistic she's not healthy for
girls this limited understanding of who
girls are is not acceptable we have to
make such a drastic shift to get people
to care about Barbie the overall problem
is being judged by our outsides not our
in size it starts with just changing the
ideals that we set forward as what a
normal body looks like
feminism and how a girl sees herself and
self-esteem for girls to put that all on
the tiny plastic shoulders
Abdallah is quite a burden I don't think
I've ever been involved with something
that's culturally significant is this
we're taking their really big step
forward
[Music]
I don't want Barbie to be history